the second season of the mandalorian has
landed on disney plus
and as audiences navigate through the
haze of excitement surrounding a new set
of space western adventures
let's take a moment to consider the
important questions like who was that
one-eyed guy at the beginning
and where have i heard his voice before
it's not cool to talk business
immediately just enjoy the entertainment
in the opening scene of season two's
premiere mando and his young ward visit
a shadowy underground fight arena
full of colorful alien characters
there's a twilight at the door
there's a zabrak chilling ringside a
pair of gamorians rock and sock one
another in the center of the arena but
the star of the scene is undoubtedly
gore koresh
the cycloptic crime boss mando goes to
meet he's a member of the abbeson
species
a race first spotted in the mars eisley
cantina in a new hope
distinguished by their single eyes and
ability to heal from almost any injury
that ability might come in handy after
mando refuses to swap out his trademark
mandalorian
garamer for information gore sets his
goons on our hero
only to watch his staff get taken out
one by one a brief chase ends with gore
hanging upside down from a street light
like so many low-level spider-man
villains before him as ominous red eyes
close him from the shadows he's scared
he's enraged and his voice is the guy
who played the live-action luigi
star wars has become infamous for its
celebrity cameos in the last few years
with daniel craig and jason sudeikis
making almost unrecognizable appearances
as stormtroopers
and simon pegg taking on a role as a
junk-dealing man-sized big toe
naturally a semi-cgi cyclops gangster
his prime real estate for a sneaky movie
star appearance
and the voice of gore koresh was
provided by none other than john
leguizamo who you might know is said the
sloth from ice age
tibolt and romeo and juliet and most
infamously luigi mario in 1993's
live-action adaptation
of super mario brothers he has more than
150 acting credits on his imdb page
rising to stardom in the early 90s
thanks in large part to his role in
carlito's way he even landed a golden
globe nomination
for his work in tu wangfu thanks for
everything julie numa
luckily the high-profile 1993 failure of
the virtually unwatchable super mario
brothers
didn't end his career he went on to land
roles on some of the hottest tv shows of
the decade
including medical drama er and childhood
staples sesame street on which leguizamo
donned the costume of the iconic captain
vegetable
ever the restless performer leguizamo
also took time to get back to his stage
roots
starring in the 1991 off-broadway
production mumbo mouth the 1998 broadway
run of his own one-man show freak
and the 2001 broadway debut of his
second autobiographical one-man show
sexaholics a love story
if you're one of those highbrow
mandalorian aficionados it's certainly
possible you recognize leguizamo from
one of those performances
although his recent mandalorian
appearance marks leguizamo's debut in
the ever-expanding star wars universe
the actor has been a mainstay of genre
films and tv shows for some time
he played clown aka violator in 1997's
gritty adaptation of image comics
transgressive
he also portrayed the og wish-granting
genie of the lamp in 2000
arabian nights miniseries aside from
lending his voice to just about every
version of the prolific ice age animated
franchise
he also voiced jack spratt on three
episodes of shrek spin-off puss in boots
the man clearly has no problem applying
his talents to anthropomorphic
creatures of every shape and size so a
towering space cyclops really isn't too
far out of his wheelhouse
in recent years he could be seen in the
critically acclaimed miniseries waco for
which he was nominated for a daytime
emmy and in the john wick franchise on
top of that he's also continued doing
voice acting work on animated series
like bojack horseman
where he played mr buena ventura in the
episode planned obsolescence
and elena of avila and the role of the
battery loco
while the rest of the upcoming guest
cast on the mandalorian is being kept
under wraps
it seems like a short bet that we'll see
more celebrity cameos
be sure to check back for the latest
news on the styles behind the aliens in
the series star-studded
second season check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about star
wars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and to
the bell so you don't miss a single one